okay people joining this livestream I am
out on the road today so different
resolution of screen but we are doing a
language incremental development meeting
and we've got a number of things which
are hopefully getting closed off in time
for version 12 so first up we have
percent form and I assume I can run that
I assume that I have a version 12 here
that I can run that it is it in the head
branch build we matched it to some
changes today but most of it should work
I mean it has been merged things
question time okay my computer is
refusing to charge that's a different
issue
okay okay by the way what's this tag geo
vector and whatever is protected that
looks like a bug in the today's build
prints with numbers in expert given as
percentages looks good okay what
questions are there here well first you
can have a look at some examples and we
did change the for example in the first
example excellent it's beautiful and one
thing that was needed during this work
was that we had to generalize one option
of number form called sign running it
was a boolean before now it is now it
can be a
a double a list of left and right so
this is following what number padding
does and number signed us they are both
double ins as in a way it wasn't done
from the very beginning it's very much
okay I don't have a problem with that
can you adjust the documentation yes we
can
I think we're pretty much dead for the
example with the counting form is where
it I understand but but sign padding has
not been updated yes we just wanted
first to join with you yeah yeah I don't
see a problem with that okay where are
we knitting percent form
do we know where our number form is yeah
probably I mean I think it's a really
good function so I took it something
over here I will do the honors of D
future isin um well I'm decimal form
also so I assume decimal form points to
percent form prolly not yet we hun done
it in here
okay I mean you'll probably do more more
knitting up and let's take a look Alice
seems to be a thing called display of
numbers as well as number digits best
decimal form on that page ah there let's
just mention it here is that beeping at
me it's really odd ah weird oh maybe I
didn't start da key tools here display
of numbers where is decimal form Oh
display without scientific notation okay
[Music]
I think this is important enough that it
should get its own little section here
section not just a line I see I think a
line well I think a line is okay but I
think I think we should separate off
these ones because these ones I think
are a little bit different so let's just
say I see what to me yeah probably
accounting form should be with with that
first group yeah the other ones see form
to look different
I'm prepared to put a carton form down
there I don't think it's very commonly
used okay um
however accounting form should certainly
points to percent form Oh another thing
that should point to percent form and
percent form should point to is some
stuff about units where's the page about
units the things about displaying what
what's the thing that displays units in
a particular way yeah I think it's what
I was talking about and this by the way
quantity forms should probably be
mentioned here
yeah I think this should mention before
style should mention percent form and
here we should have a thing for saying
[Music]
displaying quantities I mean arguably
this should go someplace else on this
page we all specify how units should be
units etc should be displayed is that
right for my quantity I think we'll okay
all right if there may be a little bit
more knitting there but that's some
check the backlinks on some of those
functions like scientific form and so on
accounting form something beep there
okay what was that what just happened
that that was a another version that had
been open somehow let me open this
agenda in 12 oh here
hold on one second
[Music]
just one second okay all right let's go
on to the next thing
keys values second argument yes so the
idea here was to be able to wrap
something around the values like extract
dust this is useful when there is
holding needs or evaluation programs yes
I think this looks good
yeah we have had examples there's
nothing to need here maybe there is
actually in the section about doing
things without evaluation
let's check did this match to hold for
example that did we map this we might
want to wherever we have where we
discuss hold this is relevant I think
yes Sandra on our livestream mentions
that the percent interpreter should also
mention percent form can somebody see to
that please
what does this gray mean I think it
means don't use this as a primary what's
up I think it's excised is it I think it
may mean don't use this to tag backlinks
to say this alright that made that one
the formatting works Sushma Sushma
Sandra and live stream masters percent
from work with percent quantities what's
the answer to that some quantities
already well it's probably going to show
percentage-wise twice okay so if I say
this percent okay okay and now I say
percent form oh that is not good what
does that mean well it's 100 but it's
wrong because this this I mean what what
how do you get rid of this do you say
normal of that yeah normal will turn it
into it so that is a bug if I might say
so guys consent form really should work
with the sake do this and not do the
wrong thing
simply impose it's
it should simply impose its what am I
saying it should impose its formatting
and then get away so to speak I mean I'm
not sure because if we if we have any
other unit it should work right well
what what should it do within other
units change the percentile to meters
okay well actually why don't I change it
to could be a background noise please
guys let's change it to degrees
background noise please could you get
rid of it um okay so that's very screwy
what that did again I mean I think this
is correct because it's multiplying the
number by a hundred adding the percent
and then it has the unit outside okay
but this is clearly not correct the
percent form of a units of a percentage
quantity so I think it's following the
general rule but we can add an exception
here that would have to go into the code
of percent form of be careful with
quantity so I think that's what we have
to do yes now is there any other I mean
because I think that case is not what
you would expect right with percent and
certainly not the double percentage
thing now what happens if we do things
like permille don't we have that in here
I guess okay so now the percent form of
that per mil thing what should that be
incidentally one extension of percent
form that we might consider at some
point is to you know do that is to allow
things like per mil and so on I'm
thinking that perhaps the right thing to
do here is not let percent from go in
such quantities I don't think that would
be by I think I agree I mean I think
these are pathological types of input
and
not allowing percent for him to go
inside hardwiring that would be just
fine which is which just means it just
leaves whatever the quantity said yeah
um percent for him just does not affect
the number yeah that's the right back
yeah would be my preference yeah I agree
that's the right behavior there are
already some exceptions like don't touch
fractions and things like that so fine
then just add that exception and
document it okay okay um okay in such a
fractional part yes we are the three
singly numerator denominator so this is
same type of thing only far more
controversial but some common saying
that the right way to do these to
implement it to be twice as mean as the
same speed as to not destroy actor a
capabilities so so the integer part
would return a the same type as the
input right um this is a really weird
name I have no idea what that I see in
such a fractional part I didn't know
what that meant I mean I understand it
now that you've explained it to me
what's the issue with the back to a
thing I mean that's an implementation
assume yes no no it's it's it's a design
problem it's fundamental what's this you
for every number we are going to return
a pair and that pair for for machine
reals is going to have an exact integer
and a machine real okay so I mean okay
but that's what it's returning right
well I think it's an unavoidable feature
yeah that may that means it's going to
be much slower on
so what it's an iceberg there's nothing
more to say for you there's nothing more
to say there I mean it just doesn't you
know yes eventually we'll be able to
pack those things and then this will
pack but until then it won't because
it's returning as you say an exact
number and a machine integer now the
only thing it's a really kind of a weird
name yes it's following the tradition of
numerator/denominator but in this case
we are already breaking it because it's
not integer part for chocolate so I'd be
fine with giving it another name like
integer fraction that's really what I
would like well what you know what it's
doing for rationals is converting more
or less to a proper fraction but I don't
think we can use that terminology yeah I
mean it's it's as in it's converting to
a mixed fraction right big ok sure I
believe that's correct term it's mixed
versus improper and by the way we are
seeing hearing a lot of background noise
for them if flu sneezes again I'll just
shoot him no no no no it's just you seem
to be on speakerphone there I'm not am I
ok um what would happen well the problem
is we might imagine a rapper mixed
fraction that represents you know 3 plus
I mean we have that weird thing don't we
for invisible plus or did I miss
remember that that there's a there's an
operator that you can put
in the middle of a mixed fraction am I
making sense I don't know I don't recall
this yeah it's it's it's there in the
typesetting system um so I mean to me
calling it mixed fraction parts fashion
pair extraction parts someone is saying
am i mixed fraction is a bad bad name
but um so let's let's recall what this
thing is doing so it is giving it is
turning something into a mixed fraction
but it is not an extraction form I mean
this would be more like two mixed
fraction except that it isn't really a
mixed fraction because it's a pair well
the idea of a mixed fraction itself
would be a formatting form but yes I
understand the mixed fraction pair see
I'm thinking about elementary users
where this might actually be I mean
they're never going to do integer
fractional part right in fixed fraction
parts was something you'd suggested
right mixed fraction parts yes okay yeah
I could go with that do you think that's
better than mixed fraction pair pair
it's more specific about everything or
wish to I wonder whether these things
have a name in the elementary math
literature what do you what do you call
the the two pieces of a mixed fraction
in elementary math literature the
integer part two words and the fraction
part two irrational
a mixed number a mixed fraction from the
Oh at least we have something on math
world that's more encouraging mixed
fashion is in improper fraction written
in the form n plus R over s let's see
whether people have a name for this a
mixed fraction is a whole number and a
proper fraction combined
well okay so the question is between
mixed faction pair and mix I think
having mixed fraction in the name is the
right thing um so the only question is
the mixed fraction parallel mixed
fraction parts I'm starting to lean
towards pair although still thinking I'm
just looking up here the only problem is
that then it might be a pair of mixed
fractions
okay what about mixed fraction list well
it has a simple it has the same problem
young from mixed fraction no I don't
like that either it would be from
improper fraction which is the way long
and the problem is we don't want to say
too mixed fraction because it isn't
actually a mixed fraction correct
well okay so what are our choices our
choices a mixed fraction pair which is
sounds are like it's a technical name
and mixed fraction parts which sounds a
little bit less technical to me it's the
parts of a mixed fraction thoughts well
using part aligns better with integer
part on fractional part good point
let's go with mixed fraction parts okay
let's do a renamed here
you
okay let's check that we can write this
correctly okay
well we could this documentation could
be left exactly the same
I think so okay all right let's do
feature eyes now I mean this probably
wants to find its way onto the
elementary math pages let's not do this
knitting right now see if you can see if
you can knit this okay unless well let's
just see it's just if we can find where
integer part is numerical functions
integer functions numerical functions
Wow
it's very prominent at the top there I
think we'd have to list along with those
it's a little weird do you think we
should list it as a whole line
underneath there to explain what it is
[Music]
now let's just put him you can mine
that's strictly speaking it's not what
we call a numerical function because it
doesn't return the number I'm not sure
well some of these numerical order
certainly doesn't return a function of
that type I think it should go here I
mean I might argue that it should be on
a separate line because it's gonna be
incomprehensible here everything else on
that line is totally comprehensible I
think it should be a separate line you
know
do you want to say proper fractional
part where's that to obvious that's
pretty obvious
okay now this probably wants to go in
gosh I mean really it goes with these
guys doesn't it it's a little weird
putting it tum as in division related
functions yeah could go there it's a
cousin to quotient remainder yeah but
those are all much more mathy true
alright I think there's a page for more
elementary functions we should find that
but let's keep going on what we need to
go through now okay okay uncertainty
that's her yeah yes
so probably biggest change here recently
is that working on the typeset and it
became clear that having the number case
and the vector case is a problem because
we don't want a vector plus minus or
matrix okay and also because the
statistics team separates normal
distribution from multi normal
distribution I think we should separate
around and vector wow isn't that I mean
what is vector around mean vector around
we'll take a vector in the first
argument and a matrix the covariance
matrix in the second argument so before
around was taking both a number in the
first argument or a vector why isn't it
list around it could be list around this
one
I think vector sounds a bit more there
were wise the matrix as well well
because we don't have a concept of the
covariance of AX metrics against itself
so I rank for object that's never used
so but but so okay so is there a page
for vector around I've just added one
very right so the idea would be that
those two cases were covered also in
Iran itself before but this was leading
to a problem for example do you mean if
you have a two case is that the
isometric error as well so I think it's
going to be a lot better to separate
this case so hold on a second so you
were saying so around itself has the
possibility so if I say around two three
point five so this works in X cannot but
so right now what I am I'm suggesting is
that this will list they will fret this
is the discussion we had recently as
well of what to do with an array of
arounds so that it's going to require
yet another concept where quantities
what the heck that's a separate problem
can somebody look into that please
that's the X kernel so there's a
recommendation page for around okay
let's try the around so you say around
three four comma point five you are
proposing that that right now it doesn't
threat and I think this
threading is a dangerous thing why well
I'm just thinking about this I mean okay
I'm following quantity here as well
what is quantitative in our case it
threads now these forces eventually the
addition of quantity array but if
because right now we cannot support
around with a list in the list
operations it will eventually to have
some sort of notion of a round array if
needed that is able to handle things
fast like quantity right yes because the
other model to follow here is that of
your position which is able to hold all
the numbers inside in the first argument
but your positions are not a vector
space you cannot add them so there is
very few there are very few actual array
operations you need with your position
but with quantity you need all of them
and with around is going to be the same
thing I may understand your statement
that they don't make a vector space
why is that I mean they're not Euclidean
vectors
I mean why why aren't your positions
coca he'll explain it imagine that your
position of London and your position of
New York what would be there is the
addition of M so in curved space
positions do not form a vector space
there is a vector space tangent to each
point and that's why we have the G
vector family now to describe that
vector space attached to each position
to each position that's interesting I
mean that's interesting I've never
really thought about that before yeah I
understand so there's no sense in which
in curved space you can have positions
form vector space no it's a general
property you have in order to work with
vectors you have to go to the tangent
spaces and then you have vectors at each
position and then how do you communicate
the vector space cool
of one position with the vector space of
another position is a complicated thing
that leads to curvature I see I see I
see that's the connection that's where
that's where you have a connection
exactly if the connection dictates how
to go from the vector space of one point
to the vector space of another point
fair enough okay
I mean it's kind of obvious right that
yes okay that's obvious given that one
knows that connections exist okay I had
not thought of that that before that's a
good argument we should remember that
argument for the next time somebody
reports this as a bug it's not it's not
our bug okay I then I agree with this
argument I mean is there a notion okay
so the generalization of a round to for
example a Geo position what is that
because clearly in a round of a geo
position is you know that that relates
also to your geo distortion business and
so on right because the around of a Geo
position could be I mean we obviously
have geo disk but if you have an
uncertain geo position right then you've
got something which is a different you
know yeah I mean can you comment on that
yes so eventually your position should
support around latitude or around
longitude never don't think that's the
right thing right because I'm in it and
in fact the you know around the North
Pole for example right it's it's what
you actually mean is I want it to be
some I mean this relates to the spatial
statistics business as well you want it
to be you know a kilometer of
uncertainty around the North Pole I I
see what you mean yes so that's yes so
that's the condition with your disk so
perhaps what we have there is a disk
with a notion of uncertainty and
uncertainty radius yeah so will be zero
position around roughly so I'm using
this to understand your vector around
case so I mean we don't have a lot of
things that are called vector the start
in the other yet
right so there will be a few now coming
with exactly with the optimization but
this is different
of course we could follow multivariate
like mu T like the statistics TAS or
multi around like no no it's horrifying
but it's totally secure yeah I mean if
we're gonna do that I think that the UM
okay so listen
they lost ability of around I'm okay
with that um although as you say we're
gonna end up with an around array if it
becomes critical to manipulate tons of
this fast
I think that's unavoidable because
otherwise the operations will have to go
one by one like the same promise with
quantity well actually no that's not
right because quantity the whole point
about the quantity array is it's the
same unit for lots of things with the
around it's not going to be the same
uncertainty for lots of things that's a
rare case yes but my point is that we
can hold internally a packed array of
numbers in a factory that's that's our
problem I mean we don't have to expose
that to the user the fact that some list
of arounds could be represented
internally in some pack form is our
Aesir yes but we will need a
representation so this is like a top
level it could be internal just like a
packed array is internally represented
yes yes okay so let's come back to the
vector around question are you happy
given all the other vector greater
vector less and so on are you happy this
was added in this version wasn't it
vector greater yes optimization right
but is this consistent with the with
vector greater is the vector around
consistent with the way that vector
greater is working well vector greater
is comparing two vectors so we could say
that once we have vectors around vector
great that could compare vectors around
and take it account that they have an ax
certainty to decide whether they are
greater or not this sort of thing
yes
well there isn't a notion of greater for
around numbers right what what is the
notion of a rate of greater for around
numbers so I say this greater than
around minus 3.1 yes do it this doesn't
work right now but the idea is to
compare them the widths of the like an
interval so so as if do you think that's
the right thing to do
well there are two possibilities here
and I have been thinking quite a lot
about them so either we can purchase the
numbers or we follow for example what
were the numbers with finite precision
do numbers with finite precision have
some sort of fashion of overlapping
which is like 60 percent of the
intervals and then you consider that hmm
that's interesting I mean I would have
thought we need to something like that
for these mm-hmm yes I'm also thinking
that people will expect that if for
example if one interval is included
inside the other we say yes of course
these are all things we say yes for
gradually it could equal to for equal
exactly I mean this problem is also
exists with equal one do we consider
that two arounds are equal yeah I
understand as opposed to triple equal
double equal right
yeah that's tricky typically is clear
double equal is the one which is kind of
yeah that's a very interesting problem I
we hadn't come up before I mean so my
guide there is to follow what numbers
with finite precision do yeah I think
that's right but what happens with
sorting around well that depends on the
numerical or turning on the ordinal you
are using by default it will use
canonical order whatever canonical order
decides already yeah I understand but I
mean cannot order just like I mean
numerical sort has to decide numerical
sort should do something sensible for
around right so a numerical sort is
specialized in three things currently
which are numbers quantities and dates
so this is a fourth object that needs to
be other day
Yeah right with thought exactly as well
so in numerical sort also handles
intervals especially and I think they
are the decision so there are there is a
lot of lots of literature on ways of
ordering intervals and there are many
ways many different ways and the
decision right now is to be very strict
so if they are fully separate we can say
one is greater than the other one
but as long as there is one overlapping
even one point then greater and equal
will refuse to return true or false
okay that's the current decision yeah I
mean arguably we want to have some kind
of boy we want to have some variants of
the greater-than functions and things I
mean this is tricky I think
greater equal should do something by
default which is relatively reasonable
they compare in a bit yeah and then we
may have more powerful functions later
to talk about compatibility and are
these compatible to so many Sigma's or
compatible to this confidence level this
sort of thing
yes I understand or alternatively mu
might end up with an option to greater
for instance okay let's look at vector
around though so I'm kind of warming to
this idea of calling vector especially
if you don't think you're gonna be able
to do higher rank tensors no I think
I've never ever seen that okay so if you
say X 1 X 2 and then there's a single
uncertainty there it will apply to all
of them presumably yes yes so so one
number with being you is the same for
all of them but the general case here is
a matrix which basically means it's the
squares of the previous one so this is a
covariance matrix which means is that
it's the squares of use in the diagonal
plus the correlations in the non
diagonal arguments it's very weird that
it's the square of the you're saying the
u sub i's in the first case they're in
the second case the diagonal is the
squares of those user buys
yes yes that's exotic yes the test we
very well explained in there but that's
not the case for an ordinary coherence I
mean it's an ordinary the the matrix is
not a covariance matrix normally it is I
mean if you go to covariance matrix and
statistics no no I said I'm saying for
around the second organs were round
normally yeah there's no covariance
because there's only one very there's
only one thing exactly for a number it's
just one you yeah all right this is
convinced me that vector around has to
be separate yeah it's it's mean it's not
a matter of more functionalities just
extracting functionality which which was
mixed in around before to to this
function this is very good this this
mean around that's a very useful thing
by the way I would do it without a
random real here I would just do I mean
this is not a good example just just do
a mean around of a list of numbers okay
um okay so we have a look at the page of
around itself so here then the main
thing I am still considering is how to
call the parts so right now I'm calling
best value X and then uncertainty I
don't like best because a central value
primary value because here two natural
names are sent center I mean but of
course once we deal with the asymmetric
case they have not good names because
people may expect we sent down why don't
we just say represents an uncertain
number with value X and uncertain to you
that's fine that's fine I think that's
what we should do okay
so best is something I've taken from the
literature it's used sometimes that's
not I mean let's just have best value
and the key words here okay
okay okay great yes oh yeah I thought I
thought flatten a ball it's a bet we've
got several things that have come in
recently for royalty we're not gonna
have a chance to review him right now um
but I think flatten a ball is a is a
better name for what we were calling
flattened right the last name we came up
with was flattened yeah I know
I prefer flatten a ball to that and
there's a new idea which is a tally idea
this is this idea of replicated seven
which is basically a way of
parameterizing with stability so that
would happen by default replicated seven
means you replicate it into that list if
you understand what I'm saying
I see so for example this if I were to
say replicated seven eight that would do
five plus the list seven eight six plus
the list seven eight isn't that a nice
idea what about if we have symbolic
stuff we have V so a product related
problem that we have had all the times
is what happens if I know V is a vector
but I need to hold this son temporarily
so that I can replace V later yeah I
understand that's that's unreplicated
that's the opposite okay
let's schedule this for a different
meeting and and flatten a ball also okay
I don't think I can look at these right
now I'm Jo distance care
and so on it's a long discussion so I
just had it there in case we had time
right so the concept here are clear
there is one little thing which we need
to discuss which is this is a quotient
and and we need to discuss decide
whether it's one way or the inverse
because the way this is typically done
in in cartography is in the way in which
large-scale maps correspond to small
scales which is horrible and it's
mentioned in there in the Wikipedia page
that this leads to confusion so my
suggestion here is to have the reverse
so if large-scale maps correspond to
large distance scales but I don't know
what the true distance scale is but
maybe if your distance ratio would be a
better name but I don't know what this
doesn't look like a ratio actually it is
a ratio because the map coordinates it's
basically the distance that corresponds
to one in the tick's of the map the
scale that is typically represented as
one color on one hundred thousand of
course it assumes that you have a paper
map that you can multiply by a hundred
thousand a distance scale is an awful
name for that I mean if that's if that's
one unit in the Mercator map so it's
right it's a ratio you have to multiply
your unit of them up to get the actual
distance yeah I mean it's like it's like
the Geo grid position stuff it is going
from right grid coordinates are the ones
on the ground as compared to is it how
does it relate to geo grid it's it's
basically geo the question of Geo grid /
geo or geo / Everett so do you
understand so this is the units of
geogrids right if you want so so miles
here so the distance scale is now
defined as geo divided by geogrid
so it's how many miles in
the actual earth divided by how many
units in German right right but
unfortunately traditionally is defined
in the opposite direction and it's
called some things like point scale okay
we need to I mean we need to have a
separate discussion here I mean this is
basically I don't understand what the
one unit is how do how you saying what
the unit is here it's is your model if
you say that you're more that is the
mean then you will get that slightly
different but what's that what's the I
mean there must be a division of the
earth into some number of you know
pieces right how do I know what the
that's enough so so the the the size of
of the earth is controlled by the Geo
model option and then the size of the
map is controlled by one of the
parameters of the projection which has a
default for example for Mercator
longitude is given fast degrees so these
numbers that you're seeing how I see
it's a degree okay so that means is this
is a degree in the Northeast direction
this is what a degree because lat/long
are both in degrees right but there is a
slight problem here which is that the
projections distort these things so
Mercator for example doesn't touch
longitude but it modifies latitude so so
these numbers that we see here are not
real latitude because my cutter sends
the pole to infinity in in quotes
latitude yeah but I mean the fundamental
units are degrees I mean it seems like
geo degree distance will be a better
name something like that its degree for
Mercator for other projections maybe
radians it depends on the parameter that
you can choose freely in the projection
so so it's a question of what you do on
the earth and what you do on the map and
you have the full freedom of choosing
both okay how about your projection
scale
it's called distance because there is a
separate function to do the exactly the
same thing for area so they said your
area scale so sometimes when you are
integrating area over a map you need to
know this ratio for area all right
to be discussed don't know a solution um
okay great
all right talk to you soon then okay
okay bye-bye
Thanks